[Music]
in this enjoyment then is revealed what
that divine risen light really is
enjoyment is the mystery of its being
for the mystical is not concealment of a
secret or ignorance
but consists in the self knowing itself
to be one with the divine being and that
this therefore is revealed
only the self is manifest to itself or
what is manifest is so only in the
immediate certainty of itself
but it is in this immediate certainty
that the simple divine being has been
placed by the cult
as a thing that can be used it not only
has an existence that is seen
felt smelled tasted but is also an
object of desire
and by being actually enjoyed becomes
one with the self and thereby completely
revealed to the self and manifest to it
that which is said to be manifest to
reason to the heart
is in fact still secret
for it still lacks the actual certainty
of immediate existence
both the certainty of objectivity and
the certainty belonging to enjoyment a
certainty
which in religion however is not merely
immediate and unthinking
but is at the same time purely the
certainty that is known by the self
paragraph
722 is a surprisingly rich little
passage there's a lot of things coming
up are being referenced here and
connected with each other
all within the framework of the cult
that we've been exploring this entire
time not just in this subsection but in
the previous subsections as well and
here
hegel begins talking about enjoyment
something that he's talked about in the
past but now this becomes front and
center enjoyment gnuse right he also
talks about the
mystery and the mystical and that's
going to require a little bit of
explanation there's some reference back
to this duality along gender lines that
he's introduced as well and just
referenced
in
the previous paragraph
and
there's a lot of other distinctions that
are quite interesting
coming up as well as
including an invocation of reason or the
heart so let's let's see what we've got
going on here
he says
in this enjoyment then
is revealed what the divine
risen light
really
is enjoyment is the mystery of its being
now that's one of those lapidary
statements like spirit is a bone that
people read and they're like oh man now
i understand exactly what hegel is all
about of course if you go back to the
phrenology section the whole point is
that spirit is not a bone and we should
try to reduce it to that
uh enjoyment is not simply the mystery
of its being or you know we're going to
get a little bit more clear about what
what it's being means there
but
it is important at this this stage right
so
what is he telling us in enjoyment in
enjoyment on the part of who
on the part of the worshipper the
individual self who is part of a
community within the cult who is part of
uh an intergenerational
continuity as well who is part of an
ethical nation right
and all these are descriptors and you
could say formers
of the individual and they are in
relation to the divine being
as well there's no point to this without
the divine being so in this enjoyment
is revealed what the divine risen light
is enjoyment
gnuse
is the it could be satisfaction too is
the mystery mysterium
de zelda and so of its being is kind of
periphrastic here it's referring back to
what it really is the east of it so you
know being zion okay that that does make
sense
what is
being revealed here what is
being uncovered here and i should point
out too as well that we've got two
different terms
that are being used here
and it could be easy to confuse them or
think of them as merely
synonyms with each other you know where
hegel is engaging
in play on asm ferratan right
is is something that's being used here
for revealing
orphan bar
orphan barong is
another word that's going to be used
later in the next
and final subsection of religion for
revelation so manifest
is actually uh open bar right
and
read revelation into that the god is
engaging in some
self revealing to the self who is the
individual worshiper and in this case
enjoyer
so
all that said we should go on past the
first sentence so we've got a discussion
here a very brief discussion about the
mystical that's mistishi right
for the mystical is not concealment of a
secret or ignorance
so this is important
when we see hegel
very rarely talking about the mystical
he is not a mystic there are some
interpretations
out there especially who want to tie
hegel into hermeticism
or into whatever other hobby horse
people want to ride
hegel is eminently not a mystic
hegel is all for
bringing things to the point where
it's not just like the province of a
select few those who have been initiated
into the secret no he wants everything
out front and center and in some ways
you could say he's a little bit
impatient with those you know fussy
mystics who want to keep everything to
themselves as that which is hidden as a
great secret hegel is you know you could
say there's gnostic themes in hegel he
is not a gnostic mystic right and in
this case he's saying listen with this
the mystical is not going to be just a
secret that you're initiated into as
part of a cult and it's not just
ignorance i'm going to pause on this for
a moment
i think there's a very common
misunderstanding of the term
mystical and it's probably crept in in
part because of
goofy people who you know wanted to
appropriate the term for themselves and
use it for whatever nonsense they were
peddling uh and it's also a result of
people in the 20th century
using mystical or metaphysical as sort
of terms of a program to try to reject
doctrines oh that's mystical put it
aside it's not philosophy right
so
ignorance
doesn't make something mystical
prime example of this for catholics is
you have these people i'll tell you kind
of a funny story i had this
this not really a friend more an
acquaintance
when i was going to the newman center
back in
graduate school down in southern
illinois
and he was one of these what we now call
trad catholics traditional catholics
that are not actually traditional at all
because they usually don't know much
about tradition except what they've read
in a very modern reconstruction of
tradition be that as it may
he was all on fire about having gone to
this latin mass in this place in some
you know some other parish right and i
asked the guy
you don't know latin do you and he said
no no i don't and that's what makes it
so awesome i can just like be there and
the words kind of flow over me
and it's very mystical and i was like
you freaking knew ager you're not
traditional at all
latin was great for people who
understood latin
syriac is great for people who
understand syriac
greek is great for people who understand
that the whole point of the service is
that you understand what the hell is
going on my my uh great grandparents
used to have missiles that would you
know this is a very common thing when
the mass was still in latin it would
have the latin on one side which they
didn't know
and then the vernacular language on the
other side in the case of my relatives
french but in many other people's cases
english or spanish or pick whatever else
you want the point is to actually
understand
what the hell is happening not to say
oh it's so feels so good because that in
fact would be more like the
sense perception or a confused type of
desire rather than something that
provides meaning
intelligibility in a robust and
substantive way so
what is genuine uh mystic mystical here
the self knowing itself to be one with
the divine being and that this therefore
is revealed
not secret revealed it comes out we
understand what things are
so he says only the self is manifest to
itself or what is manifest is so
only in the immediate certainty of
itself but it is in this immediate
certainty that the simple divine being
has been placed by the cult you could
think of the cult as a place
and time and locus
and tissue of meaning in which this
simplicity becomes possible this is one
reason why when we look at other
people's cults from the outside we might
not understand what it is actually like
for a believer a worshiper a member to
go through that we approach it in very
mediated ways like reading textbooks and
you know world religion class or taking
a visit to the local pick whatever you
want right it's not quite exactly the
the same but within the framework of the
cult this immediate certainty is
possible now notice what he says next
as a thing that can be used it not only
has an existence
that is seen felt smelled tasted right
so there's this use there is this
engagement with the divine being perhaps
through its statute perhaps through
singing hymns perhaps through whatever
it's going to be and that is a sensuous
experience so you know we can talk about
this in terms of religions that are
rather iconoclastic as well to sit in a
quaker meeting
waiting for
the you know uh whatever is going to
prompt you to to speak
and to notice the surroundings that is a
sensuous
experience right it's going beyond that
but that is part of it um to
go to a
zen center and look at you know the
stuff within the the meditation hall and
to go to a shrine and to go and walk
through the garden that is sensuous
there's elements that go beyond that of
course
to go into a temple and see a figure of
the god
laden with
vestments or
drapings or whatever else it is and to
smell the incense
that also is sense perception so
that is part of what the cult offers but
that isn't all that there is
he says it's also an object
of
this
takes us all the way back to where
before the master slave dialectic
self-consciousness remember what is
religion
supposed to be doing uniting
consciousness and self-consciousness in
a way
that allows for the fundamental desire
of self-consciousness to be satisfied
remember what didn't happen after the
master slave dialectic and after
stoicism and skepticism the unhappy
consciousness this is not an unhappy
consciousness
this is a consciousness that is being
fulfilled that is finding its desire met
in something by being actually enjoyed
vehicle right uh
it becomes one with the self and thereby
completely
remember i pointed this out revealed to
the self and manifest to it
open borrowing
revelation
manifestation in this this translation
is taking place here
this is this is very
important so this the desire of the self
reaches out to the god perhaps we can
say even the god has desire and
enjoyment comes back from the god
treating the god objectively not just in
terms of all of this sense perception
now here hegel says something that is a
little bit
counter-intuitive given the rest of the
passage
that which is said to be manifest to
reason fernand to the heart
is in fact still secret
why
you can't have a purely
intellectual or purely
emotional
relation here there's got to be
something holding that together you can
say the cult is providing part of that
but it's also what we could call the
play of the human
faculties
why it still lacks the actual
certainty of immediate existence now
notice what hegel says about the
certainty here
two different
modes of certainty
the certainty of objectivity
gegenschtenli kite right
being objective being a gegenstein
something that can stand in front of us
something that we can look at i mean one
of the things that's nice about having a
an idol or uh you know adelone in greek
of the god something that we can look at
is that we can all say hey you see that
thing over there let's all turn and face
that could be a crucifix you know it
could just be a bear cross it could be
um you know thinking that that uh we're
gonna have a blank space but there's
something
for us to treat objectively when we say
open your hymnals up to page 36 and sing
him such and such that's also part of
objectivity we're all you know
doing the same thing engaging with
objects
but he says that there's also a
certainty belonging to enjoyment
what does that mean
you know
i'm not going to say all enjoyment is
pleasure
because it isn't
there's other components to this
but
when you feel pleasure you know you're
feeling pleasure right you may be
confused by the pleasure you're feeling
you may not be able to fully appreciate
it because you're not a connoisseur and
there's elements of it that you're
missing out on but it it's it's in your
face right if somebody says i don't
understand what it means to feel
pleasure you'd say
i don't know how to help you buddy and
enjoyment is kind of like that there is
a
immediate certainty
associated with that and he says that
in
religion however this is not immediate
merely immediate part of it is immediate
but part of it is
something more
and it's not unthinking
it is bringing thought in it's not
necessarily thought like academic
thought or you know the kind of thought
that tourists have when they go in and
they're like how am i supposed to be
appreciating this temple you know
but it is thinking
thought is involved and he says but is
at the same time purely the certainty
that is known by the self so there's a
kind of
self ratification that is taking place
here that is taking us out of the
mystical as mere hiddenness or ignorance
and giving us an initiation and
something profound that we can
experience not just through sense
perception
but through the play of desire
and
enjoyment or satisfaction
what has thus through the cult become
manifest to self-conscious spirit within
itself is simple essence as the movement
partly out of its dark night of
concealment up into consciousness there
to be its silently nourishing substance
but no less however the movement of
again losing itself in the nether
darkness and lingering above only with a
silent maternal yearning
the moving impulse is however nothing
but the many name divine light of the
risen sun and its undisciplined
tumultuous life which similarly let go
from its merely abstract being at first
enters into the objective existence of
the fruit and then surrendering itself
to self-consciousness in it attains to
genuine reality and now roams about as a
crowd of frenzied females the untamed
revelry of nature in self-conscious form
paragraph
723 working off of the previous
paragraph still focused on the locus of
the cult and the mediation that it
allows between
self-consciousness of the worshipper the
believer the human being and the divine
object the entity the god
very clearly focuses on the cult
of dionysus and demeter right and all of
this sort of stuff so can we generalize
this we would have to transpose
some of the objects and the
manifestations being discussed but you
know we can certainly learn something by
looking at where hegel
is going with this and i think if you
want to understand this you have to look
backwards at some of the other
passages paragraphs even going back into
the last subsection before this right so
a paragraph
721 talking about these
two different
principles the feminine principle of
nourishment the masculine principle the
self-impelling force of self-conscious
existence and then going back into
paragraph 718 where he's talking about
um the act of the cult itself the the
bread or the grain and the wines the
living series and bacchus themselves so
you want to keep that
in the background but
he says what does thus through the cult
become manifest to self-conscious spirit
within itself now self-conscious spirit
is
self-consciousness of the individual
human being the worshiper who is part of
a community part of a ethical nation
right
but it could also be said to be on the
side of
the god to some degree
and the cult is what is uniting them
which doesn't have the implication by
the way that
with the cult gone or broken
it may not have the efficacy
in the present
that it did back then
so he says
self-conscious spirit is simple essence
as the movement
partly out of its dark night of
concealment up into
consciousness so we see the motif in the
last paragraph of what is mysticism
mysticism is not about hiding stuff
mysticism is not about ignorance
mysticism is not about woo spirituality
it is about revealing things
the mystical winds up being what does
get shared and brought to light revealed
right brought into
a
a shared experience so he says that um
there has there there to be a silently
nourishing substance
but
no less however the movement of again
losing itself in the nether darkness in
in what is nether right
that it which is below
that which
remains below something that we've seen
discussed much earlier in the spirit
section
so
losing itself again in the nether
darkness and lingering above only with a
silent
maternal
yearning
so we've got this polarity of masculine
and feminine coming up again we've got
the nether darkness
inhabited by this silent maternal
yearning uh
is the term that uh
miller is translating there so maternal
definitely they're yearning definitely
there right and
so this shows that desire is not just on
the side of the worshiper there's also
something on the side of the divine to
show itself to connect itself with us
and then he brings in the masculine the
moving impulse is however
nothing but the
many named filin amen divine light licht
of the risen sun
and its undisciplined tumultuous life
now the undisciplined tumultuous life
the the german doesn't actually have
that it just has you know uh talmud is
which could be tumultuous could be
staggering could be reeling
could be undisciplined if you like it
could be you know the general thing is
it's kind of flailing about it doesn't
it has
desires but it doesn't quite know how to
realize them so we've got
desire on both
we won't say sides let's say polarities
right we've got the feminine and the
masculine
and the the feminine is expressing
itself through this
sort of incohat yearning that is not
being articulated the moving impulse is
perhaps too articulate it's all over the
map
and we get a really interesting
crossing a chiasm if you like a chiasm
is a rhetorical figure which is an x it
comes from the greek word he right x
and
which you know looks like like that
and
what we've got going on is both the
masculine and the feminine being
demarcated differentiated but also being
mixed together and interfused because
this tumultuous
life
is going to show itself
as the masculine in something that's
directly tagged is feminine
and this
sort of mute to desire
mother-like desire maternal desire
is also going to show itself in what is
being offered
to the worshiper for consumption again
going back to paragraph 718 in the
previous paragraph discussing how the
cult works so he says um
this moving impulse
undisciplined tumultuous life which
similarly let go
from its merely abstract being
first enters into
the fruit
but the fruit here is a stand-in
not just for fruit but for the wine
the
bread
the grain whatever it is that we're
offering and consuming right and we
could say the vegetable products we
might also
tie this in with the animal sacrifice
although we don't need to hegel's being
you know he's leaving that to the side
um and this this consumption is of
something that has a dozen it it has an
existence
um but it's not just an existence he
says objective existence gegenstendika
right
so
this is something that the
self-conscious worshiper
in the services in the rituals
consumes
and consumes as part of the
meal not just with the god but
of the god
because this you know the sun has
produced the fruit right but also the
soil has produced the fruit it is given
the the
body of the god in a tangible form that
going back to the previous paragraph can
be smelt tasted seen
i guess you could say herd if you're
slicing it and there's let that sloppy
sound slicing but more you know oh more
odor and taste and sight right i guess
you could say touch as well
but then there's another aspect to this
so
he talks about it as surrendering itself
to self-consciousness and attaining to
genuine reality so it surrenders itself
uh it's described as zeke himself in
gaben right to self-consciousness
what does this take on genuine reality
as opposed to objective existence
genuine reality
eigen leakin
reality
actuality
presence
more than just mere existence
but here's where it gets very
interesting how does it take that on
is this like super fruit no it's not
about the fruit at all now
except perhaps the fruit providing a
mediating thing as perhaps fermented or
something like that
here is where we see so this tumultuous
life
taking on some other dynamism and here
he talks about it as being in the
presence it roams about
as a crowd
of frenzied females
is how um
miller is translating it haulfin
schremender viper right um the untamed
revelry of nature
in self-conscious form well how how does
it self-conscious it's human beings
running around like you know for example
the worshipers
of dnessas
who sometimes engage in some pretty wild
stuff
and we could extend this to fertility
gods and goddesses more broadly
the fruit itself is not self-conscious
right the fruit is something consumed by
self-consciousness something in which
the enjoyment that we saw in the
previous paragraph takes place but even
more enjoyment takes place through
activity
so we have these two sides
on the part of the god expressing
themselves the desire
that is
their mute hidden active producing the
fruit perhaps also feeding into the
frenzied crowd
and then the moving impulse of the light
of the sun
that can be too many things and
is brought to self-consciousness through
this crowd which
you notice self-consciousness could look
at
as something apart from itself or it
could
participate within
you